welcome to this special edition of
discover Germany DWS travel guide
today's program is devoted to Munich a
Bavarian city that maintains its
traditions the capital of Bavaria Munich
is considered a cosmopolitan city but
traditions some dating as far back as
the 12th century are still fiercely
upheld by locals and while there are
certainly plenty of spectacular sights
to see many visitors appreciate the
relaxed and friendly lifestyle
cultivated by the people here
the spire of st. Peter's Church is one
of the best spots to get a view of the
city
the 306 steps are well worth the climb
on sunny days you can even see the Alps
in the distance famous landmarks such as
the frontier or Cathedral of Our Lady
and the navien plot square are spread
out before you the neo-gothic town hall
attracts visitors from far and wide
every day at eleven and twelve o'clock
the sound of the glockenspiel entices
people to watch the Cooper's dance and
once re up an aristocratic wedding
ceremony
the fish woman fountain is a popular
meeting spot for locals and tourists
setting off to explore the city
it's only a few minutes away from
Karlsplatz
locals prefer to call the spot stockist
after a munich innkeeper they think that
names more connected to the place than
the non bavarian prince carl ever was
munich kings used to like to relax near
water
the nymphenburg palace was once the
bavarian rulers favorite residence the
palace was continuously renovated and
kept getting bigger the Rococo style
banquet hall dates back to the middle of
the 18th century in 1845 the most famous
bavarian king ludwig ii was born in
what's called the Queen's bedroom
another attraction is the Deutsche's
Museum or German Museum in the city
center opened in 1925 it's the country's
most visited Museum the fallen namitha
Anglophone name is actually the German
Museum of Master works in Natural
Science and Technology the short version
is German Museum we're not a history
museum though we're all about Science
and Technology technic engineer oscar
von miller founded the museum to
showcase discoveries and inventions to
the general public from steam engine to
the mission to explore space museum
welcomes 1.5 million visitors each year
when locals feel like relaxing outside
they head for the 'english a garden or
English garden the park opened to the
public in 1792 and the idea was for
everyone to have access to green space
right in the middle of the park is one
of Munich's biggest attractions the
Chinese Tower beer garden space for
7,000 people its Munich's largest
drinking spot
thanks to a special 200 year old Munich
law visitors to the beer garden are
allowed to bring their own food as long
as they buy beer or knock out front you
bring cheese or chicken like we have
others might have sausage salad or a
cheese dish like Bavarian or Baxter you
can bring bread and plates whatever you
want you get the best combinations of
food and the nicest thing is you get
chatting to other people would assume is
a condiment unknown right Nance cosplay
another popular drinking spot is the
Augustina Kellogg beer garden near the
main train station it has space for
5,000 people opened in 1812
it's the oldest in the city Bavarian
beer gardens might date back 200 years
but they're still as popular as ever
let's now take a closer look into
Munich's history many aspects of the
present-day cityscape bear the mark of
Bavaria's kings and princes some of the
most splendid architectural gems such as
the State Opera and the magnificent
Maximilian Strasser are legacies of
former monarchs
this is a man who shaped eunuch lute fig
the first was crowned King of Bavaria in
1825 at the time just sixty thousand
people lived in the city bluetick built
a lawn and on a large scale
the residenz palace had long been a home
to Bavarian monarchs but lute fig had it
expanded and when he wasn't at home his
subjects were welcome to visit its
grounds the gardens are still a popular
place to go strolling today
the palace interior is a monument to the
Bavarian royal family's splendor in 1920
many rooms were open to the public for
the first time
the most impressive room in the building
is the 66 meter long Hall of Antiquities
it's the largest and most lavish
Renaissance interior on the continent
north of the Alps
maximilian ii succeeded ludwig the first
by then Munich's population had grown to
100,000 Maximilian son ludwig ii
ascended the throne in 1864 and went on
to become world famous thanks to his
support composer Richard Wagner was able
to premiere many of his works in the
city's Opera House Ludwig is said to
have locked himself in his private box
so he could enjoy the music undisturbed
nowadays the Bavarian State Opera is
open to anyone and is one of the leading
houses in Europe horse-drawn carriages
used to stop here now you can take a
tour of Munich's famous shopping Avenue
Maximilian's closet with a taxi
we're on Maximilian Stasi which was
built for maximilian ii our third king
almost all the kings except ludwig ii
immortalized themselves here
construction of the stream started in
1851 in powell afternoon at an infiniti
next to rule bavaria was Prince Regent
luige cold in his day 260,000 people
lived in Munich maximilian lhasa is
still one of Munich's finest addresses
and it still boasts shops that bear the
proud title purveyor to the Bavarian
royal house only makers of the finest of
wares were given the honour of holding
the Royal Warrant the world-famous
Hotpoint house also owes its existence
to Bavaria's monarchs they expanded the
breweries and allowed beer to be served
to one and all these days thanks to the
kings tourists from around the world
party here with Bavarian beer and what
would munich be without oktoberfest held
every autumn it's one of the biggest and
best-known parties in the world and it's
where we met up with Bruce and Kellie
Finkelstein from the United States they
had just one day to spend on what's
known as the reason but they certainly
made the most of it
hi I'm Bruce Kelly and we're from
Virginia Beach in the United States and
we're big fans of Oktoberfest and we're
gonna explore the visa today
thank you Vigo Bavaria
we really like Oktoberfest and we've
been preparing for a while I've got the
later hosen which I bought online and
I'd like to sell so I made my own dandle
okay we're here in the oil of easin
where they have the traditional rides
and attractions stuff out of the 20s and
we're gonna go see how this works
all right let's go
all right you ready
it's really great that they have these
older rides this one actually makes you
have to work which is great there's a
lot of fun I haven't done something like
that since I was a kid playing in the
kindergarten
with the it's the wobble wheel bicycle
race
I can't tell who's winning and who's
Stella he's usually pretty good on a
bicycle she's having a tough time
there was a lot of fun it was good you
did a great job
and one of the things I really like
about the Oktoberfest is when you sit at
a table you sit with all other people
you don't know who you're going to sit
with and it's great because you get to
talk and make new friends
I could eat this every day where can I
move to Bavaria
well we're getting ready to ride on a
ferris wheel and I do believe this one
is made of wood this is something out of
the I guess the 20s and we're looking
forward to getting on the ferris wheel
and and getting a look at the vision
from a little bit up higher even the
tickets are made of wood
it's been a great day the reason today
we hate to say goodbye we made so many
friends but why
leaving the hustle and bustle of
Oktoberfest will indulge in a rather
different cultural pursuit Munich is
also a paradise for art lovers with more
than 80 museums the city has something
to suit everyone's taste from old
masters to works by Andy Warhol Munich's
Len buck house the renovation of
Munich's most popular art museum was
four years in the making
museum come from Mosiah the word museum
comes from you Zion which means the
temple of the muses where the muses
danced so a museum isn't a static
unmoving institution I kind of started
in Switzerland the new annex hold stage
of the art exhibition spaces
just down the road there's the alte
Pinakothek the art museum opened in 1836
it holds works by European artists
dating from the 14th to the 18th
centuries most pieces were originally
owned by the Royal litters Bock dynasty
the collection includes paintings by
many old masters among them Alpesh doula
and Titian Dietetic chapters the old
Titian is wonderful with his crown of
thorns it's one of the loveliest
paintings and at the Thurston bill
Rubens is amazing but it's too much
flesh and just two masses the Rubens
collection of the alte Pinakothek is
world-renowned at over 6 metres high and
4 metres wide the great Last Judgment is
Rubens largest oil painting
you
di de pinna the alte Pinakothek plays in
the major league it's one of the world's
most famous galleries thanks to the old
wittelsbach family's passion for
collecting under the reign of king
ludwig the first of bavaria munich
became renowned as a city of art in 1830
he commissioned the Glitter tech museum
on Kunak splut square to hold his
sculpture collection
it contains sculptures from the archaic
period to the Roman era the necrotic is
the glyph to take his Munich's oldest
Museum which is itself a mark of
distinction and it was created by a
Ludwik the first personal the shop phone
for nutrition yes he was a connoisseur
of Greek and Roman art and an admirer of
classical antiquity Ludvig the first is
also to thank for another museum the
Neue Pinakothek with a collection that
focuses on the 19th century
it holds works by Carl Othman Ludwig's
favorite landscape painter and
acquisitions such as Italia and Germania
by johann friedrich Overbeck Ludvig the
first elevated the status of art like no
other bavarian ruler the powerful was
seen building museums and amassing large
art collections was a very important
aspect of his monarchy KT to thine
ultimate ease they were always to
contribute to popular education and to
transform the kingdom of Bavaria into a
center of art and culture and quit were
started to buckle
although the days of royal patronage are
long past in Munich art and culture
still hold pride of place in the city
one new addition is the brand Horst
Museum which opened in 2009 the striking
building in the gallery district houses
a large collection of modern and
contemporary art including what is
Europe's largest holding of works by
Andy Warhol the pop art icon is a major
draw card for the museum in a nearby
underground station students at Munich
saccadic eye narcs have staged their own
exhibition this installation is set into
motion by the wind of the subway
entering the station the space to the
side holds more exhibits by young
artists
the works all revolve around the same
topic as lead addendum our breakfast
the idea is to observe how the surplus
energy generated by urban life can be
put to creative and artistic use
the art students are often there to
demonstrate and describe their works the
gallery is located at the University
subway station art in motion it's just
one of the many cultural attractions
Munich has to offer time now to meet
censure and shadrach skull art from
South Africa on their trip to Munich
they visited the BMW museum the
world-famous car maker built its first
vehicles in Munich about a hundred years
ago and just across the way is Munich's
Olympia Park planned and constructed for
the 1972 Summer Olympic Games
hello I'm Cedric
hello I'm Sencha we are from Cape Town
but this is our apartment here in Minich
and we are here to show you the city of
Minich let's go
thinly adorn is ending at or as one of
three gates this used to be the city
wall surrounding Munich in our room this
that one money
yarv isn't year but we're here at
sending a tour and we're traveling to
the Olympic Center stop on the u3
underground life
18:56
amazing the souls got the original seeds
and to get the nice steering wheel is
fantastic
ah no here's a BMW 650 they have the
same motorcycle at home habit deserved a
motor out two hours
try to pick yes yes
okay can I get it what's your hat okay
here we go
I think it's fabulous I mean they even
thought about open rooftop in the year
1957 I mean very 59 that's great
the engine is a bit louder probably the
age of the car but I think it's a fun
car to be on a Sunday morning
this is the olympic tower we're going to
see now okay and I'm holding up the
tower welcome to little with big color
at 291 meters in height the city taller
ceilings highest building and the
horizon it almost looks like ocean is
really just perfect but they they you
have the Alps in the distance you see
the up some snow on the OPS's
so putting the money and then choose b1
June don't make me cry
take a good and making bad remember to
let into your heart will start to make
it good this is about party
the day was very nice I particularly
enjoyed the BMW World you awesome I'm
also looking for absolute was a memory
like out of Munich and Germany we love
you Germany thank you
and that's all for this special edition
of discover Germany the Travel Guide on
DW join us again next week